this right here is my very first camera
and i'm just about to be fetched by
casey to fly to dubai and for the most
part i'm going to try and film it on the
sky
words to live by he's so tired
so it takes off
five minutes
oh my nose looks huge
[Music]
welcome to dubai
oh it is stunning
we have arrived at i'm on floor 19
casey's on floor eight four four eight
four
be on floor four
what's really funny is casey and i
always have this joke of who gets the
better hotel room this time it's me
[Music]
casey and i've been flown to dubai to
shoot a video about an incredible new
museum called the museum of the future
but unfortunately i won't be able to
shoot on this camera well it's just a
little bit outdated so i'm gonna have to
move over to my sony camera
it's currently 8am in dubai and the
intention of shooting the museum video
is to be completely alone in there at
night so we have the whole day to kill
here in dubai
[Music]
now i've been taking best serving in
dubai the best surfing in dubai yes okay
what do you think he means by the best
wave in dubai
[Applause]
dan pro surfer how was that
much better than i thought all right no
no no no no don't put that in because
it's sort of like [ __ ] no you i just
asked you to tell me how the wave is how
was it dan absolutely fantastic
really no
how was the surfing dan no the waves
were great i told you
the waves were great
[Music]
with these hands
i will be so uncomfortable with your
legs wrapped around
the tree
i don't know that that was the best wave
i've ever
surfed but it was fun
[Applause]
[Music]
you would have almost gotten hit
this is a g master my brother [ __ ]
where's the cover position can you watch
this but make sure i get that lens back
make sure i get that lens back i'll make
sure you get the lens back this museum
has been described as the most beautiful
building in the world and it's not hard
to see why at night it lights up with 14
000 meters of arabic calligraphy and
what's even better is that we have this
entire place to ourselves
[Music]
this place is ginormous
[Music]
i've completely lost casey
[Music]
casey
casey
what is going
[Music]
casey
i found casey
this is some kind of magical carpet that
quite literally makes you feel like
you're walking on water and this place
well i have no idea
thinking happy thoughts
darkness
there's so much more to explore
[Music]
never at home probably a busy person yo
then lastly we entered this kind of
playground area which i think is for
kids but we still had fun oh are you
like right up here with me
[Music]
keep riding just hold on hold on don't
get in my way i really don't want to hit
you i don't want to get hurt
it's pretty
good go liam
let me just get a shot of just liam
coming out
why are you so smart
all right let's go downstairs i wish we
didn't have to catch a flight in two
hours and that i could have spent more
time here it's honestly
incredible if you're ever in dubai i
would highly highly recommend checking
it out
[Music]
i don't actually like american chocolate
i swear to god i understand
it tastes like
like salt mmm what a day
very full day dan maze it feels like i'm
always saying goodbye
well we live
sixteen thousand seventeen thousand
miles apart but you're going back to
south africa that's true
i'll see you in south africa
cheers have fun
[Music]
why are you coming with me right now
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
from
[Music]